ああああああ
まあネットも繋がらはいすいませんえ
ネットが繋がらないのでコメントは夢ませ
今日外れ社長です僕のせいじゃないんで
怒らないね皆さんはおかしい何が好きです
か今皆度にいるといろんなを稼ぐあります
よねえぇこの季節は特に味ものシリーズ
増えています様々なお菓子があるだか何々
風味1号アーチとかバナージ抹茶チョコ
などいろいろあると思うんですけれども皆
さん何が一番おいしいと思います小ヴァン
ダーが一番美味しいんですよ
[音楽]
俺の統計によると今のところ僕がちーてる
食べてきた中でそのシリーズのバター絶景
ハズレがないんです全部美味しい的で今回
こちらに本目にで売ってたパター時のお
菓子を全部買わせていただきました一番つ
とか結構あったんですけどバター塩入れと
少ない全ての箇所の会社が今外したくない
バターズで外したらうちは終わりだって
ことでなかなかを出しづらいんだと思い
ますね開発とかで知らんけどという意味で
今日の動画はもう食べる前からわかってい
ます1個イブ格付けルアープチ
アヴェダ一石二ヶ月に美味しいのはわかっ
てるんですけどもバター全部混ぜて食べ
たら一番おいしいお菓子ができるんじゃ
ないかバカなとバター地の場所にマジで
外れないですよ本当に今回それを作って
いきたいと思いますで愛子
神首
ではさっそく紹介していきましょう全部
12社でやりましたねまずはこちら北海道
リッチバターなんかねすごいこと書いて
あるんですよバター醤油味ではなくバター
味が食べたい凄くないですかもうお客さん
の治療としていやいや馬体が入れなよとは
イタチはバーターでパペたイベント処理だ
ぞい learn デート行って作られた
北海の日中バター2まあそれぞれバターの
事情ってあるんですよまじでいただきます
[音楽]
本当にどんな意はい
日本一嬉しいです次はそっちこちら
ディアーの使用バターキャラメルまたタン
ビンではないんですけどもまぁ使用バター
外切り許せるかなと思い買わせていただき
ましたこのタイプのお菓子ね r rr
これそもそも普通に食べても美味しいん
ですけどもそれをさらにバター風味にした
ということで私はどんな味になっているの
でしょうかいただきます
ああ
ああっ
海楽2がコツはまりはまりまり映画から
まだいいかなわからんですこの時期だけの
特別なあず by 発酵バター子だけです
ねっと行き止まりで食べてみたいと思い
ますでいただきます
[音楽]
勝った
なるキャンプ地入りてる奴だっ
ちょっと血が出ましたあの感想としては
なんか周りのさっぱり釜に登ってますね
これとさっぱりした味わいだったけど
パターン数で確かに感じられますが
おいしいおいしい2世はこちらふにゃてに
はミルキーバタージープにゃたのする新
触感ということで懐かしいなこの感じ3月
のバターズでふにゃ視点で詳細子ちゃんっ
てあげます
だから宇宙だねうんまん
家の子ですねはい中のミルキーバージョン
というかそれにバター持たされててもう
銀河一美味しいです続いてはこちら伏せ
なおなんと糖質が9.2グアムかなり
抑え目です発酵バターを使われてクッキー
なんですけどもこれ奥永ダイエット意識
高いとか結構食べてたんですよ
めちゃくちゃおいしいですよ糖質が
しっかり教育委というのにすごくおいしい
という聖五位アンフロ食べてしまいます
いただきます
うう甘さ控えめって書いてるんですけども
結構ああなって進んでも美味しいですよ
これめっちゃ好きです
266店続いてはこちらビーフ本を発酵
バターを使われていますとおいしくて
つよくなるこの言葉は行って成長するの
でしょうか一方昔はよく食べてた記憶が
あるなぁ全てが懐かしいじゃあいただき
ます
[音楽]
パミあじゃあねそもそもビスクは甘いのに
それはバター子だ手にすることによって
本当にうまいんですよ案件道じゃないです
かね委員行バラバラなんで別にあるどこか
にこの年通いそういう所信と頑張ってじゃ
ないんだことなのは公平な目ではとさん
入っております何してくださいアペンド子
じゃないですよ
[音楽]
お仕事まずしていますそれではこちらで
当たってやってるゲイうわぁ
で散ったこういう頭はちょっとやめて
欲しいよねはじめちょいでこちらとっこ6
本パター時点だねこれは買ってますねと
コナー香るバタープレッツェルんだよ
うまいでしょどう見てもパッ is 金色
やモールは中のチョコにはバター疲れてる
んだエロ付いております
[音楽]
me
いうことが二文句ないですこのか車完成し
てますおめでとうございました
馬と全然子育てバター舐めたことない
でしょう飛ぶぞ
[音楽]
なにこれ
なにこれ名前強北海道で作ったバターを
使用して作っているバターキャンディと
いうことですねこれだから新商品ぽい何見
たことないですですこんな染めた名前のお
菓子うわあああっ普通に美味しそうです
いただきます
とっていたうん
3月甘い場合は飛ぶか飛ばないかというと
飛ばなかったすけどただ飛ぶに近いくらい
おいしかったです本当にすごいバター慣れ
してて俺が今もうスってこちらドラゴン
ポテの幸せパターンこのぐるぐるって待っ
てるのはドロンパ強くやつですねそれの
バターズでございますねんかね意外と
バンダー系のポテトチップス多かったん
ですけどもこの純バターバターしかない
みたいなあんま中割と母の不純物プレート
時食べて今回は本当にパターだけして
もらっていただきましたそういう場だとか
七夕会てると某地増えたらかなり増えたを
分地でありますん
[音楽]
まあねじれてるから周りにパウダーが
たくさんついてるのかわかんないけど
めっちゃおいしいいやもうこんな絶対
美味いじゃんと言うでも辛くランキッズ
ワット運ばターンはいもうおいしいで背徳
感を丸数いって書いてるカプはすごいなん
か
きとるんだろうなぁ
もう人で超こういう時ばかりはメッツは
そうじゃうわーもう
いただきます
白魔宇宙までしねこれバザーとクランキー
チョコ好きな人はこれだけ食べてください
[音楽]
あかーん残りは負担ですねこれは木買い
ましたまた焼いちゃったたかけるんですよ
ああーこういうなんか舐めた感じの名前
ですけどがっちゅうまで飛びに変え染めた
中でこれあったんですけども俺一人でと7
袋ぐらいと言いましたバターっぽい見た目
せるんですけどもなんかねえカントリー
マアムのバターバージョンのような感覚
です本当にも
イヤホンもんね死んだからホロホロって
めっちゃ後味 points よ超濃厚
バターなんじゃないんあ下すああ下すあっ
管進めばこれも悪魔の食べ物だよマジで
そして最後はコチラハニーバター
アーモンド
アーモンドナンパの中にアーモンドが
ぎっしり入ってますいただきます
ん
me
が中まだが中まだこれ
[音楽]
ん
全部は全部呪いの食べ物だバター1尾を
するなぜここまで開く特定の誰かに簡単に
押されてしまうんだ食べてるの背徳感が
ハンパねぇというわけで
web もんだワンハニーバター
アーモンド
バッグ入れちゃったクランキーチョコ1巡
と発行ばカードラゴンパスしあわせバター
独歩変わる語って丸い使用方すんな国会
ブリッジだにゃべで見る姫バターバター
舐めたこと会社とくぞで一箱ばたちだって
リア塩畑
さーん術亭のバターズの歌詞が入ります
さあ見た目的には十人十色と言いますか
ポテチカンディクッキーチョコレート
いろんなものが待っておきますですが
すべてパターチで死亡ダガー時の想像つい
て受けようただどういう食感になるのかな
ということのバーター乗ろうのみたいな
部分吹雪になっているところがあります
うわぁ
[音楽]
おっ
ヘ一瞬でこんなになっちゃった
[音楽]
を
破るない悪だというわけで完成しました皆
さんこれが史上最強のバターズ伸ばしばた
ね t フィパウダーファンロクマル零式
15でまずは香りから楽しみましょう
バターが通りですそれはそうかじゃあ
いただきます
あ
ん
[音楽]
4日
ん
ええっ
おっ
マークよくないわこりゃきっとあいつ区で
壊せてみようもちろんすれ違う1回した
これぞお願いしまーす喧嘩するわけないん
ですよぜバターズだからクランキーチョコ
のバタークリームをちゃんとしてるしたか
世の中のバター好きの人の気持ちを全部
ゲット一握りした感じでこれあかんで
ほんまに
[音楽]
人たちが1回全て微調整これ大丈夫の粉
混ぜだけん
かっわずか2分社杯ではこれやっぱりいい
結局なとんああ
ものこのめっペット分ば浮上へ行って屋台
がすごいなめらかでべてみれば全部混ぜて
みたんですよう
それは馬柄はこれ美味いよねー
めちゃめちゃ馬コ商品できるやばくないん
羽毛
[音楽]
羽毛はばっっ
elr